storybook an open source tool used to
build test and visualize ui components
in isolation modern web developers love
component frameworks because they
organize html css and javascript code
into reusable chunks like lego bricks
however a complex codebase can still
easily descend into chaos causing
components to lose their meaning in life
storybook allows developers to extract
components into a sandbox where they can
be explored and tested without
distractions instead of viewing
components through the lens of a giant
complex component tree that is your
application you get a guidebook that
breaks everything down individually no
need to worry about data dependencies or
business logic this makes it much easier
to share your work with other developers
or clients who can validate that things
actually work the way they're supposed
to in addition it has a test runner
based on jest and playwright that can
automatically verify whether your
component renders without errors and
also validate concerns like
accessibility measure performance and
can even do visual regression testing in
the cloud to pinpoint everything you
broke with that last css tweak to get
started create a project with your
favorite front-end framework like react
angular view spelt and so on or open an
existing one then run npx storybook init
next find a ui component then create a
matching file ending dot stories.js a
story is just a function that describes
how to render the component in many
cases a component will have multiple
different variations to show in the
story export a function for each one of
these variations that works but we can
actually change the arguments to a
component dynamically directly in the ui
by creating a template that maps
arguments to the component we can now
change the component's behavior on the
fly directly in the storybook ui it's
also possible to write stories in
markdown with mdx this allows you to not
only visualize the component but also
document it at the same time and there's
a huge collection of add-ons to
customize the behavior of your storybook
you might use actions to keep track of
browser events or viewport to analyze
components on responsive layouts and the
measure add-on can help you visually
debug css layout and alignment issues
within your stories when it comes to
testing you could spot check with your
own eyeballs or use the test runner to
write automated tasks and run them on
your ci server and finally share your
work with the world by publishing it as
a static web application this has been
storybook in 100 seconds hit the like
button if you want to see more short
videos like this thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one